salut a tous j'espère que vous vous
portez bien aujourd'hui donc vidéo très
particulière sous la forme d'une enquête
qui a nécessité de longues recherches
mais bon en haletant avec le confinement
il ya quelques semaines nous n'avions
pas réussi à sortir de l'eau ce qui
semblait être un coffre dans une partie
du canal du midi riche en trouvailles
nous sommes revenus équipé d'un treuil
et de pleins de bonne volonté
[Musique]
mais pas bien passé
voilà là où on en est donc encore une
fois on a utilisé le treuil à fond pour
arriver jusque là alors on sait pas du
tout ce que c'est que ce truc il ya des
inscriptions en bas qui sont en train
d'arriver donc on va pouvoir
un pouvoir avoir une idée de ce que
c'est
c'est assez bizarre voilà ces trois
traits là
mais ouais je pense que la marque qui
emballe va nous permettre de
l'identifier la chose au niveau poisse
et c'est incroyablement lourd
incroyablement lourd
allez on continue après plus d'une heure
d'efforts acharnés nous avons réussi à
sortir la bête de plus de 150 kg de pure
forme
c'était un calvaire pour décrocher les
aimants
lorsque cela apparaît à la surface
stupeur ce n'est pas un coffre
quai ouest à quoi correspondent ces
inscriptions est ce une marque
nos recherches commencent alors que west
est une baie située en floride c'est
bien mais ça nous avance pas trop qui
est ouest est une marque de petits
bateaux de plaisance américaine
probable dans un premier temps mais nous
avons vite écarté cette hypothèse en
effet cette marque n'est pas distribué
en france et cette pièce ne correspond
pas du tout à un bout de bateaux nous
continuons donc nos recherches et enfin
le quai ouest piano bar de villeneuve
les béziers tristement célèbre pour être
la cause de la fusillade d'agde survenu
le 5 août 2010
et pourquoi ce qui semble être un
présentoir de menus se retrouve-t-il au
fond du canal du midi selon nos
recherches le quai ouest a ouvert début
2010 dans une zone industrielle abritant
des boîtes de nuit rapidement le gérant
est victime de chantage par un groupe de
quatre individus affiliés au grand
banditisme biterrois l'un d'entre eux
gilles car douville alias pageau a déjà
été écroué pour meurtre alors qu'il
était vigile dans une boîte de la région
il est reconnaissable par les stigmates
d'une bagarre à la pioche qui lui a
coûté un oeil et la trace laissée sur
son visage par une balle alors qu'il
jouait à la roulette russe dans le but
de prendre le contrôle du quai ouest le
groupe de malfaiteurs multiplie les
intimidations en juillet 2010 il
cambriole le quai ouest emportant tout
sur leur passage télévision piano sono
selon les articles et très certainement
ce présentoir à menu vous là explique
aussi sûrement les parties de véhicules
découper retrouvé dans le canal les
choses n'en restent malheureusement pas
là le 5 août 2010 le gérant l'un de ces
vigiles et son pianiste tombe dans un
guet-apens sur les bords du canal du
midi en plein après midi d'août alors
que des pêcheurs et des touristes sont
présents sous une fusillade éclate le
vigile est tué d'une balle dans le dos
le gérant est touché à la cuisse tandis
que le pianiste criblé de balle parvient
à s'en sortir en se jetant dans le canal
le quai ouest n'ouvrira plus jamais ses
portes et le bâtiment qui l'abritait a
aujourd'hui été démoli
l'afer a eu un fort écho médiatique
notamment à cause de la fuite en espagne
du principal accusé et de la présence de
l'avocat eric dupond moretti en tant que
défenseur de l'un des accusés
jugés par la cour d'assises de l'hérault
gilles car deauville et ses complices
ont été condamnés à des peines allant de
15 à 30 ans de prison
j'espère que vous avez trouvé cette
vidéo intéressante les prochaines seront
je l'espère bien plus joyeuse nous avons
décidé de publier celle ci pour insister
sur l'histoire cachée derrière chaque
objet que nous sommes susceptibles de
pêcher n'hésitez pas à nous donner votre
avis sur ce format de vidéo ou compléter
celle ci si vous avez été quelconque
information malheureusement les
informations sur cette affaire sont
assez peu nombreuses ce qui n'a pas
facilité notre travail de recherche nous
n'avons par exemple pas trouvé de deux
photos du quai ouest en tout cas portez
vous bien et on se voit pour la
prochaine vidéo
non heureusement nous avons fini
d'écouler tout notre stock de vidéos
déjà tourné on se retrouve donc après le
confinement
[Musique]